what does young fellow do there's
nothing sexier than a nose piercing and
let's see what this beautiful young lady
wants hipster strap let's see what this
little Bjork fan wants right here trend
black fishing yes it's where you dye
your skin like it's opposite of Sammy
Sosa so you know Sammy Sosa want to get
really white it's when like white people
races try to look more black yeah I
don't know that was a thing so like I
baby did it bad I'll bring up her
Instagram a second in the past people
have said ariana grande has tried it
it's just like a bunch of tan and people
can't tell they think it's racial
profiling like they think it's a little
bit of vulture yeah the appropriation
get the [__] down
people can't be tan now ok I can't get
tan for girls it's usually like the tan
the lip filler
yes yep sign me up hey is she of age or
no she's still 17 she's up
let's pretend she's 18
that [__] is bad she's is 18 she's 22
or three maybe no dude you didn't you do
a music video with her still how did you
engage with her at all no she was a
child why you got a stage like was there
any interaction when you asked if the
child in an adult and hey hey you want
to have a seat
child don't I have a seat have a seat
which is funny because of what Theo
played in this video yeah he's a creep I
have played a PDF file in defeat you and
des Leo's get casted as PDF files yeah
dude I did I'll tell you one funny thing
to have on this video said I don't have
the video but it's good music man huh
her music ain't bad well here's what
happened David Spade hit me up and said
hey you should do this music video with
bad baby right and so I was like oh man
well obviously you know I want to
impress David Spade this does and she
had just put one out that he was in that
was really good so if you look up that
one he was like a milkman and it was
really dope and I was like all this
seems you'd be something funny in it I
thought was gonna be cool yeah so then I
get there and they said y'all we use a
pedophile and I said nah man that's this
is a rumor that your character yeah and
they said that's your character boy you
got all defensive you got no proof yeah
the character those videos a fake man
well no no what so this was hers oh this
is her as a low yachty no yah-tchi
that's over my gone man
she's doing the damn thing though
[Music]
from dr. Phil to this how can you hate
this was great poison oak from
definitely and I know I'm gonna go this
video is great
so then anyways good I ended up being a
pedophile and a different yours was a
little creepy like you're funny yours is
more creepy there was one funny outtake
where I called her a wig ordering one of
the takes I should get mad huh did she
give him enough she died laughing and
and it was uh
out to find the video I had the video
somewhere okay can't even put it in the
video can you release the outtakes or no
you can't rubber I can't what are they
gonna do kill you Here I am behind the
scenes being a PDF file right there god
damn that is a pity of flop I've ever
seen and that's me also my fact that I'm
making a behind-the-scenes video in a
bathroom but uh but anyway yeah so that
was the deal but yeah there was one
great moment right oh this is it it was
during this scene and we're the wigger
joke come in at it do it was just
they're like okay just make fun of her
for like 37 you're like you little
weirder and I was like you [__] way I
god we don't need that we don't need
that energy here the whole set died
though she died too it's right by the
funnest time the funniest moment on it
but I saw her once at CAA with a
security guard so she is white I was
hoping she would say what's up but just
a security guard she was white I mean
she's transitioning now how do you feel
about that
I mean I think she's just she just looks
tan nobody she looks black I don't know
they show me the black she has some
bangers them
wait bill yeah i'm just playing a
[__] pervert
you look great though that's Bella
Thorne right yeah
ty dolla sign to with the outset with
you know the only person at forty five
million views son people hate on this
girl man I celebrate her going from dr.
Phil to this shukru like moving booming
you got to see the behind the scenes
definitely her mom was there like
running the show she had like a whole
team you know just a different universe
different universe good for her though
yeah she was pretty nice
no she was exactly like she is on these
things she's just caught up in that
little world you know just wise like
young gangster like money in the bank
now like rapper it's like yeah like
every girl that's not her [__] is
just talking [__] outside of a car wash
somebody somewhere in Tucson right now
that was the vibe like if you're not her
but of your you were like basically this
talking [__] outside of a car wash in
Tucson yeah like all the girls you see
out like a [__] hot topic no but she
made it yeah this is like a skill like
thought topic basically wigger topic so
yeah did not define that video though
it's pretty [__] funny you should
post it oh I was so excited bro when I
did it Oh music views are the [__] I
love that you're in that one no I was
excited one of y'all wig or at her
that's so funny I wish they would have
kept that yours is great dahlias is
fantastic with a [__] logic and mmm
Oh [__] Chris Nate yeah black fishing
are they use here you guys seen a lot of
that in the black culture does it upset
you I don't know what she looks like
well that'd be what she was white now
she's she's just real look at her yeah I
mean it's the girl from the video and
then that's her that's her oh here's my
thing if that's what she wants to do who
gives a flying [__] is she using the
n-word no right she's acting you know
that's what she surround ourselves with
you know
black she looks good I'm assuming she's
you said 22 she's not she's definitely
of age now man she was a 16 when she was
on are you sure right now is that
confirm I looked it up this morning I
don't wanna get in trouble either she's
a good-looking human being on the show I
think this child is out of her [__]
she needs to put on some clothes and
actor age yeah this is unbelievable and
yeah it's out of control Hey please get
me out of here but what about people
look in Asian people that are crossing
over you know people that are is it the
company white guys got their eyes done
to look Asian yeah Asian to get their
eyes done to look white yeah a lot of I
feel like more girls who are doing their
like Melania Trump thing where it's just
like the facelift makes you look a
little more you know you don't have to
do that with a lot of girls doing
Kenneth round eyes very big because yeah
pedophile what do you got - now you an
Asian file no hats eyes are already
Asian huh what I mean
Kent has eyes from her own body and hid
and region where she was oh she was born
in America weren't you yeah see all
right well you know I'm saying where
your parents were born what do you mean
[__] out of here Nick Jesus let's do
another
[Music]
the King nothing